[Music]  anthony weiner is back in the news the  disgraced congressman who resigned after  tweeting naked pictures of himself to  women on the internet has officially  announced he's running for mayor of new  york city  as i said weiner announced his campaign  today on youtube and uh it's interesting  take a look  this was my neighborhood growing up a  middle-class kid in brooklyn i thought  we had it all  playing stickball late into the night  look i made some big mistakes  but i've also learned some tough lessons  and i hope i get a second chance to work  for you  thank you for watching  [Applause]  [Music]  i i thought he would be leaner